[Musik]
hallo
meine Damen und Herren und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen Episode
Skyblock mit Luca und wir
haben heute tatsächlich gar nicht mal so
viel auf unser To-Do-Liste denn es soll
heute mal wieder ein bisschen
entspannter werden chillige Musik
bisschen unsere Insel erweitern ich
möchte heute auf jeden Fall auch zu der
Insel da hinten zu der Insel und zu der
Insel dort hinten hin so dass wir ein
bisschen mehr Erde bekommen und auch
schauen was sich dort befindet so dass
wir alles in diesem Bereich erkundet
haben außer diesen komischen
lochbereich da vorne mit diesen
Kristallen ich sag immer nicht genau was
wir damit machen soll schreibt mir das
mal bitte gerne unten in die Kommentare
und was natürlich auch direkt als
allererstes zu tun haben ist da vorne
die Monsterfarm zu reparieren da hatte
ich euch in der letzten Folge gefragt ob
ihr mir da weiterhelfen können was man
da irgendwie machen kann ob es da
irgendwelche Tricks gibt warum die
Creeper da immer explodieren und äh wie
ich das Ganze vor allem fixen kann da
wurde mir ziemlich häufig das hier
und in die Kommentare geschrieben und
zwar soll ich wohl Falltüren platzieren
auf der unteren Ebene es geht schon
wieder los mit den Monstern ich haue
erstmal fett gegen hier darf tatsächlich
niemand sein wenn ich die Falltüren
platziere deswegen packe ich die direkt
auf die Speicher wieder die ersten
Creeper die hier runterfallen ich habe
es auch tatsächlich in meiner testwelt
schon getestet das Problem ist
allerdings sag ich auch noch mal eben
eine hin und auf der anderen Seite
gleich auch noch mal ähm das Problem ist
dass es dort nicht so ganz geklappt hat
und wenn ich nah genug dran stand konnte
mich auch dort die Creeper sehen und
angreifen zack zack so wurde das nämlich
gesagt damit ist jetzt nämlich der
Abstand hier wo die mich sehen noch mal
verringert worden um die Hälfte von
diesem Bereich oder um Drittel oder so
ich weiß es nicht ganz genau allerdings
es klappt
explodiert nicht wow okay wir haben es
auf jeden Fall hingekriegt also danke
euch auf jeden Fall für die ganzen Tipps
und in den Kommentaren die Monster
fahren funktioniert wir brauchen gerade
nichts von denen wir haben trotzdem mal
wieder eine Menge Knochen bekommen und
Pfeile sind auch immer sehr sehr gut für
unseren Bogen die beiden nehme ich mal
mache die zusammen dann haben wir einen
perfekten Bogen hier den haben wir sogar
auch noch am Start ähm die sind auf
jeden Fall sehr sehr gute wenn wir dann
in der nächsten Folge dort hinten
hingehen dann müssen wir kämpfen gegen
diese komischen
Wachturm
Bewohner wie sie genau heißen allerdings
wenn wir das dann in der nächsten Folge
machen heute werde ich erstmal noch eine
Menge Cobblestone abbauen was mir
allerdings auch noch unten in die
Kommentare geschrieben wurde und dafür
muss ich mir direkt auch noch mal einige
Falltüren mehr machen und zwar genau
zack zack zack insgesamt sechs Stück
war das hier
und zwar dass ich Falltüren über die
süßbären machen kann und dann laufe ich
da nicht mehr rein weil so ist es ja
häufig so gewesen dass ich die abbaue
liegen in der Ecke und ich laufe dann
ihn wieder rein so können wir es jetzt
allerdings machen dass wir hier die hin
packen und dann laufe ich nicht mehr da
rein also Bam Bam Bam wenn ich jetzt
einsammeln will funktioniert alles wir
laufen dann nicht mehr rein
dementsprechend habe ich auch gerade mal
den hier abgebaut und den hier vorne
weil hier eine falsche blöd aussehen
würde und hier in der Ecke auch und dann
können wir hier auf jeden Fall gut
rumlaufen beim Baum wo wir auch direkt
zum nächsten Thema kommen das hier ist
tatsächlich nicht die Spawn weil es
verbunden war mit diesen Laub und dieses
Laub verbunden ist mit dem Holz
dementsprechend hatten wir hier immer
noch so ein bisschen von diesem
Fichtenholz äh bzw Fichten Laub und das
dahinten ist äh tatsächlich nicht die
spawnt genauso wie äh das dort vorne
weil wir dort in diesem Tank nicht noch
mal waren und deswegen nicht geladen hat
der hier wird eh nicht wachsen weil das
hier zu nah dran ist und hier vorne
benötigen wir auf jeden Fall noch ein
bisschen mehr Erde deswegen deswegen
mache ich mir jetzt erstmal neue
Spitzhacken um ein bisschen
viel tatsächlich
Bruchsteine abzubauen bzw ich wollte
gerade schon Bruchstein Stufen sagen
diese hier reichen nämlich leider nicht
aus denn wir benötigen auf jeden Fall
noch ein bisschen mehr um zu den anderen
Inseln rüber zu laufen und da er euch
auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal eine ganz
kurze timeless
oh meine Damen und Herren ich habe
gerade eine Viertelstunde lang abgebaut
der ist doch gerade mal kurz schlafen
gegangen die Sonne geht hier vorne auf
es ist mittlerweile echt schön wenn der
Rest hier vorne dann auch noch mit Erde
voll ist bzw mit Gras und wir hier vorne
vielleicht auch noch mal eine kleine
Farm machen für mich ist ja leider
irgendwie von der Insel runtergeflogen
glaube ich und so Freundschaft hat
leider nicht so lange gehalten aber dann
wird sie schon langsam echt Cosi
aussehen wenn meine letzte Folge auf
festgehalten dass dieses Projekt hätte
das tatsächlich länger gehen wird als äh
über Silvester hinaus weil ich es nicht
schaffen werde alle challenges bisschen
besser zu machen und wir auch noch in
die Hölle gehen können wir können auch
ins Ende gehen und ich glaube sogar in
der Hölle das wird nämlich auch in die
Kommentare geschrieben und gibt es viele
Inseln noch zu entdecken da kriegt man
auch Eisen das heißt eventuell geht
unser Traum doch noch in Erfüllung
dass wir Laub hier vorne an die Treppe
ran setzen können allerdings habe ich
gerade wirklich so viel Bruchsteine
abgebaut ey glaubt es mir wirklich nicht
wenn ich euch das jemand zeige das sind
alles die bruchsteinstufen die ich jetzt
habe ich habe mir hier auch Brot
mitgenommen meinen Pfeil alles mögliche
ich darf halt nur nicht runterfallen
das wäre ein bisschen unentspannt
allerdings euch jetzt auf jeden Fall
eine ganz kurze timelapse wie ich mich
zur nächsten Insel baue
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren da sind wir
jetzt auch schon bei der pilzinsel hier
vorne angekommen ich habe mich erstmal
nach dahinten gebaut und dann aber
direkt weiter hier den Weg zu pilzinsel
gebaut weil als ich das hier alles
fertig gebaut habe habe ich mir gedacht
Mensch
dann lasse ich es jetzt einfach an
Katrin wie wir zuerst auf die pilzinsel
die neben mir gehen und danach auf diese
Insel so dass ich dann nicht noch meine
timelapse binden muss von daher erstmal
wieder eine harakirreaktion hier vorne
den Wassereimer runterlaufen lassen so
dass wir alles von unten schön fertig
machen können zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack zack zack und wir hüpfen
hier drauf neben dem Wasser einmal
wieder mit und können jetzt hier ganz
entspannt alles drumrum bauen so dass
wir auch keinen einzigen Erdblock
verschwenden ganz viele haben mir
tatsächlich vor ein paar Folgen schon
mal wo ich mich auch rübergebaut habe
Insel haben die Kommentar geschrieben
die Sache ist dass ich gerade diese
ganzen Videos die ihr seht vorpro Tiere
weil wenn ihr dieses Video hier gerade
euch anschaut bin ich in Österreich ich
bin im Skiurlaub und Wellness Spa
bisschen mit Familie Weihnachten feiern
die langjährigen Luke Schuh Mitglieder
und Verfolger meines Kanals werden ja
wissen dass das schon mal so eine
Tradition bei mir in meiner Familie
geworden ist wir fahren immer im ich
ganz kurz ich lass das jetzt einfach mal
hier alles bevor ich das jetzt hier
abbaue das sieht so viel Zeit und ich
brauche eine ich habe ganz ganz viel
abgebaut und wir machen eine eh bald die
Cheat voll wo ich diese ganzen Blöcke
hier Weg bauen dass wenn ich euch die
Welt natürlich am Ende von dem Projekt
gebe ich diese ganzen komischen Stifte
habt ich nehme mal ganz kurz die Pilze
hier mit hier haben wir leider keine oh
mein Gott ich dachte der fliegt weg die
haben wir leider keine Kiste am Start
oder Wasser oder irgendwas krasses
allerdings brauchen diese Pilze glaube
ich für den großen mushroom den wir in
den challenges ja noch machen müssen
also erstmal jetzt hier vorne noch die
Erde abbauen zack zack also ich bin auf
jeden Fall gerade wenn ihr das Video
seht in Österreich im Urlaub produziere
dementsprechend vor und äh das Problem
beim vorproduzieren ist immer täglich so
12 bis 13 Stunden am PC sitze mit diesem
Licht hier an Videos aufnehme Schneide
und meine Augen darunter ziemlich leiden
deswegen nutze ich jede Möglichkeit um
irgendwie mal die Augen zu schließen
wenn gerade ein Video hochlädt 5 Minuten
lang einfach mal die Augen zu machen
weil man die Ferne schauen weil das ja
nicht so gut ist für die Augen und
gerade wenn ich so eine timelapse mache
wo ich jetzt nicht irgendwie ja wie bei
Minecraft Lukas Staffel 1 irgendwo
hinfahren irgendwas machen und
Ressourcen sammelt sondern mich wirklich
einfach nur vorwärts Bauern kann ich
halt entspannen noch mal die Augen zu
machen dann kommst du manchmal so
komische Fehler irgendwie das Blöcke
nicht so richtig laden und keine Ahnung
was aber das ist irgendwie glaube ich
der Map hier zu verschulden weil es ja
schon sehr anders als alle anderen
Minecraft Maps ich meine wir haben
überall
Luft
schon irre wie klein auch unsere Welt
von hier aus sieht ne klar die Monster
vom riesig aber die schwebt auch das
triggert mich auch ein bisschen wir
müssen die vielleicht mal festmachen mit
so mit so zeugen hier am Rand triggert
meinen mein architektenherz guck mal wie
riesig die dann ey minecraft ist ein
wunderschönes Spiel ne
no joke ich habe auch ein anderes Video
vorproduziert das kommt in der Woche
oder so online da habe ich auf die
besten Minecraft 1.19 seeds reagiert
sind nicht reagiert sondern ich habe sie
selber eingegeben bin in die Welten
geflogen mit so riesigen Bergen
Schluchten Vulkanen und so ich habe
richtig Bock wieder auf den Singleplayer
Projekt wenn ich irgendwelche Ideen habt
schreibt immer unten in die Kommentare
vielleicht auch Multiplayer also nicht
schreibt's mir gerne unten rein aber gut
wir dürfen nicht lange Zeit verlieren
guck mal die Farben ne wundervoll wie
das aussieht mit dem Shader aber gut äh
wir müssen mal wieder hier eine
harakir-reaktion machen an der Seite
wieder runter so dass wir keine Erde
fahren gestern zack zack zack zack zack
und jetzt hier noch kurz die Plattform
machen ah nee das klappt gar nicht so
richtig äh hier vielleicht nee warte wie
kann man jetzt dahin vielleicht auf der
After der anderen Seite müssen wir das
machen zack so können wir hier drauf
können wir den Wassereimer mitnehmen und
uns jetzt hier an der Seite wieder lang
bauen sind dass wir alles entspannt
abbauen können
[Musik]
den Baum hier warum der
selbstverständlich auch ab das ist ja so
unser wannenbaum ich fand ich auch bei
Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1 extrem
schön oder oben schwebt auch noch was
rum aber das hier kann sich schon
abbauen ja okay das kann sich glaube ich
schon abbauen die fand ich in minecraft
mit Luca Staffel 1 extrem schön weil ich
dieses Biom auch so liebe diese Savanne
das sind so weiße nicht das sind so
schöne Farben irgendwie dieses orangene
Holzart der fällt jetzt runter aber egal
ich glaube wir kriegen eh hier hin
Setzling raus also hoffe ich zumindest
mal so dass wir darauf gar nicht so doll
angewiesen sind ich brauche zur
sicherheitshalber allerdings noch mal
hier kurz eben so eine Plattform rüber
also dass wir zum aha ja ja
also das wäre nach vorne was droppt das
ist auf jeden Fall auch am Start habe
ich meine wir haben genug Bruchstein für
alles am Start beziehungsweise ja doch
hiermit könnten uns eigentlich auch noch
genug Sachen machen um heute auch noch
zu der letzten Insel dahinten zu laufen
aber gut wir brauchen noch mal eben
fixiert die Erde ab also das wäre auch
da nichts vergessen und da vorne ist
auch tatsächlich einer katzien Setzlinge
runtergefallen so heißen ja glaube ich
diese Bäume wir haben oh wir haben sogar
zwei tatsächlich danach hier noch mal
irgendwo einer den ich gerade aus
Versehen aufgesammelt habe ist sie noch
ach guck mal da kommt direkt noch einer
raus mehr Holz braucht man eigentlich
auch nicht da vorne ist noch einer aber
wir haben drei Stück komm jetzt aber
insgesamt fünf sogar glaube ich ins
Gewerbe genau fünf Stück haben wir wir
sprinten wieder zurück nach dahin ich
lass mich das jetzt einfach mal drin das
in die Distanzen so ein bisschen ach
guck mal direkt hier wieder muss ich was
essen das ist aber echt schön dass wir
mittlerweile für alles gesorgt haben im
genügend Essen wir genügend Holz wir
haben Bruchstein Generator können
eigentlich alles machen was man machen
wollen allerdings wollte ich jetzt mal
ganz kurz keine Tablet einblenden damit
ihr wirklich seht wie riesig diese
Distanzen sind die man wirklich
zurücklegen muss ich meine schaut euch
das mal an ich laufe hier bzw ich
sprinte ja richtig ne einfach mitten
durch niemanden über seine
bruchsteinbrücke mit meinem super
schönen Skin und äh bin immer noch nicht
bei der Hälfte
angelangt dafür machen doch ganz gut ich
sicher die Sachen ich fahre noch
Bruchsteine und wir gehen auch noch zu
der letzten Insel dahinten für heute
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren ein
wunderschöner neuer Tag erwartet uns
hier wir haben hier vorne noch zwei
Millionen die kann ich noch mal eben fix
abbauen ich habe mir auch vorgenommen
demnächst
ja diesen See hier irgendwie wegzumachen
ich feiere den irgendwie nicht mehr
sondern eine Akazie ist gewachsen schön
ist sogar echt genauso gewachsen wie es
mir vorgestellt habe nämlich so hier
vorne rüber und das hätten sie noch ein
bisschen weiter hinstellen können
[Musik]
naja ich möchte hier vorne auf jeden
Fall so ein kleines Feld hinmachen und
dann geht sie da perfekt rüber dann
können wir auch eigentlich theoretisch
hier dran die Fackel anbringen und
können die hier wegnehmen also eher ein
Fan davon wenn man Licht schafft durch
so Sachen die man nicht so direkt
mitkriegt die brauchen wir auch
eigentlich gar nicht glaube ich das
müsste das müsste hell genug
das Mädchen habe ich gerade schon
abgebaut denn das werden wir jetzt
einfach mal hier oben hinstellen wir
haben ja so eine kleine äh
Platzproblematik hier bei unserem
Projekt von daher werden wir das einfach
immer hier oben schlafen direkt neben
den Öfen ist ja noch irgendwas drin nee
ist nicht aber gut ich habe auf jeden
Fall ordentlich Bruchsteine abgebaut ich
habe nicht alle jetzt zu
bruchsteinstufen gemacht ich könnte aber
noch ein paar mehr eben zu
bruchsteinstufen machen fällt mir gerade
mal aufhören schon mal ein paar von
daher laufen wir jetzt wieder hier vorne
rüber und euch tatsächlich wieder eine
timelaps
es tut mir leid aber es ist wirklich
nicht spannend sich anzuschauen wie ich
Bruchsteine setze
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon angekommen
meine Damen und Herren wieder natürlich
die allseits bekannte Harakiri Aktion
hier vorne an der Seite runter ab unter
die Insel Bam Bam Bam Bam bauen zack
zack zack für unseren Weg zum draufgehen
Wassereimer einsammeln und jetzt können
wir uns hier wieder ganz entspannt an
der Seite überall eine kleine Plattform
bauen so dass nichts verloren geht von
unserer wertvollen Erde die tatsächlich
gar nicht mehr so wertvoll ist mir ist
aber aufgefallen dass wir äh tatsächlich
hatte ich ja glaube ich schon mal gesagt
äh gar nicht mal so verkackt hätten in
der ersten Folge wenn wir irgendwie Erde
verloren hätten oder wenn wir keinen
Setzling bekommen hätten weil man sich
ja eh mit den Sachen die man in der
Kiste hat alles mögliche bauen kann also
der eigentlich kann man sich damit nur
Bruchsteine holen aber damit kommt man
ja überall hin und auf diesen Inseln
hier gibt es genügend Erde wo ich jetzt
wirklich nicht mehr weiß wo ich damit
hin soll weil unsere Insel ist nachdem
wir die jetzt hier abgebaut haben auch
voll ehrlich gesagt
und man kann halt einfach auch
schlichtweg sich Holz hier holen weil
man schaut euch das mal an dieser Baum
hier ich weiß gar nicht was es ist das
eine schwarzeiche ja schwarz Eiche äh
das ist ja auch wieder extrem viel Holz
und ich weiß auch nicht was ich hier
mitmachen soll es gibt keine Challenge
mehr die irgendwie was mit anderen
Holzarten besagt und ich weiß auch
ehrlich gesagt nicht was ich jetzt
überhaupt hier gerade soll oder ob das
so Inseln sind die man dann am besten
erkundet wenn man halt keinen Holz mehr
hat wenn man keine Erde mehr hat dass
man einfach hier so ein bisschen ja
aufgefangen wird vom Spiel sowieso
eine Hilfestellung na gut wir bauen uns
ja auf jeden Fall mal ab wir haben auf
jeden Fall jetzt gerade die nächste
Entfernung im kompletten Projekt
Skyblock mit Luca zu den ersten
richtigen Gegnern die wir nicht wirklich
selber beschworen haben sondern die dort
vorne sind ich weiß nicht ob man da was
erkennt aber ich sehe da tatsächlich
niemanden aber das wird wahrscheinlich
daran liegen weil wir zu weit weg sind
ohne dass wir die sehen können die
einzigen Gegner die wir bisher haben
sind in unserer Monster fahren die haben
aber selber gebaut und selber provoziert
von wirklich gespannt was uns dorthin
erwarten wird ich baue mich jetzt mal
hier hoch um hier noch mal eben kurz die
Blöcke abzubauen so dass auch das hier
alles die spawnt und wir vielleicht den
ein oder anderen Setzlinge bekommen ich
werde eh keine schwarzeiche Pflanzen
deswegen ist es mir auch herzlich egal
ob wir einen bekommen oder nicht aber
falls ich irgendwie ja das für irgendwas
brauche hier eine Blume nehme ich mal
mit dann könnt ihr mir das sehr gerne
auch unten in die Kommentare schreiben
kurz noch die Erde ab und dann haben wir
diese Insel tatsächlich auch fertig und
das ist die letzte normale erdinsel die
wir in dem Projekt Skyblock mit Luca
wirklich haben wir auch schon schwarz
Eichen setzen komm noch irgendeiner
runter nee ist mir aber auch egal das
wird jetzt wahrscheinlich da wieder ein
bisschen kleben bleiben in der Luft
genauso wie der hinten die Blätter oder
da vorne weil einfach diese Chance hier
nicht laden guck mal da fällt noch
stärker runter aber wir kommen noch mal
wieder das nehme ich noch mal eben mit
wir kommen noch mal wieder um ähm nach
dort hinten zu gehen
und so ein bisschen Action zu machen mit
den ganzen Idioten da vorne eh komm
kurzer eine Karte bis ich da vorne bin
so meine Damen und Herren ich habe jetzt
gerade mal ein bisschen einen längeren
cut gemacht denn ich bin jetzt nicht nur
nach dort vorne zu meiner Insel gelaufen
und habe die größten Teiler meiner Items
also Erde die Setzlinge das Holz etc
gesichert sondern äh bin tatsächlich
auch weiter hier rüber gelaufen bin kurz
schlafen gegangen deswegen haben wir
noch einen neuen Tag und hierhin denn
jetzt werden wir auch noch kurz hier
hingehen dann haben wir alle Inseln
einmal durch außer halt die Insel die
wir von hier tatsächlich gar nicht mehr
sehen mit der Festung aber sonst haben
wir tatsächlich jede Insel am Start
überall steht halt irgendwie die Kacke
rum deswegen können wir demnächst auf
jeden Fall die Cheat voll machen werden
jetzt allerdings erstmal wo ist es denn
bin ich gerade blöd da
da werden wir rein das ergibt aber gar
keinen Sinn
das kann ich ja gar nicht abbauen ich
habe ja nur so eine
steinspitzhacke ein paar Sekunden später
okay
es sollte angeblich klappen von daher
würde ich sagen probieren wir es mal
Harakiri Aktion
Bruchsteine in der Hand
und wir gehen ganz entspannt hier an der
Seite runter
und bauen
uns einen Weg
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob das
ich habe ganz vergessen dass ich im
Wasser gerne Luft Kriege kann es sein
dass du dumm bist ne und da sind wir
auch schon angekommen an diesem
komischen runden Block von dem ich keine
Ahnung habe was er bewirken soll oder
warum wir den wirklich benötigen in
unserer Welt ich habe mich jetzt einfach
mal da vorne mit dem Wasser einmal
weiter runter gebaut und dann hier an
der Seite rüber mit bruchsteinstufen so
wie wir das auch bei den anderen Wegen
gemacht haben schaut euch das mal an
das sieht aus wie so ein komisches
gasleitsystem durch Rohre oder so ich
werde jetzt allerdings trotzdem mal ganz
vorsichtig vorgehen mit der
steinspitzhacke funktioniert auf jeden
Fall bei diesem glatten Basaltblöcken
das hier funktioniert auch das ist kalt
sieht hier drunter haben wir da gibt's
schon rein da müssen wir glaube ich ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein ich werde das
jetzt einfach mal alles so ein bisschen
abbauen ich werde nicht den kompletten
Kubus hier abbauen weil ich dafür nicht
die Menge an Spitzhacken mit dabei habe
und ich weiß auch nicht warum wofür wir
das hier alles benötigen oder was mir
das bringen soll das vorsichtig wo kann
man dann runter hier können wir noch
eine Stufe runter auf jeden Fall kommen
wir hier vorne irgendwie lang und ein
bisschen chilliger da rein ja das sollte
passen so äh wir haben jetzt hier auf
jeden Fall Kristalle
und der ist kaputt
[Musik]
bin ich blöd
oder muss ich den Block abbauen
[Musik]
es glitzert auch so leicht wenn ich ihn
darüber laufen so vom Sound her
[Musik]
also es klingelt so ein bisschen
ja meine Damen und Herren schreibt mir
gerne mal unten in die Kommentare was
genau ich hier tun soll was genau ich
abbauen soll und was ich da lassen soll
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal so ein paar
Blöcke von denen hier mit kann auch sein
dass diese Kristalle da irgendwie nur so
Scherben sind wir hatten das ja in
Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1 auch schon
da wusste ich auch noch nicht so richtig
was ich damit anstellen soll ehrlich
gesagt schauen wir mal
was wird ich habe hier an der Seite
jetzt einfach mal so eine kleine
Wendeltreppe hoch gebaut deswegen auch
oben hüpfen können und uns dann hier
ganz entspannt auf unsere Brücke bewegen
können jetzt setzt die anderen die
letzte bruchsteinstufe hin meine
Spitzhacke ist kaputt gegangen ich habe
jetzt 27 Jahre mit Sitzblöcke 21 kalt
sieht und 15 glatten Basalt schreibt mir
wie bereits gesagt ja mal unten in die
Kommentare was ich damit machen soll
dann was ich mit diesen anderen Inseln
genau anstellen soll weil ich da schon
eine Menge Holz jetzt habe ich weiß
nicht ob ich irgendwie Challenge
übersehen habe oder was genau ich damit
anstellen soll und äh auch bitte Tipps
und Tricks und in die Kommentare für
diese Festung mit diesem komischen
Idioten denn da weiß ich auch noch nicht
so ganz wie ich da vorgehen soll ich
weiß nicht so wirklich warum wird es
haben geht der wasserblock war irgendwie
ein bisschen verpackt da drin alles da
vorne ist weggespawnt und ich weiß auch
ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig ob ich
überhaupt mit den aufnehmen kann
denn der Sinn einer Monsterfarm ist ja
nicht nur dass man irgendwie dadurch
Level bekommt und keine Ahnung was
sondern natürlich auch der Loot und
viele haben mir geschrieben ey durch die
Monster fahren wirst du auf jeden Fall
auch Eisen bekommen mit denen du dir
dann Eisenschwert oder eine Schere
machen kannst weil mit der Schere wollte
ich ja diese Laubblätter neben meine
Treppe packen das hat allerdings bisher
noch nicht so ganz funktioniert also ich
habe noch keinen einzigen Eisenblock von
meiner da tatsächlich sehr hässlichen
Monster fahren ausspucken lassen können
deswegen weiß ich auch nicht ob ich es
irgendwie hinkriege es mit diesem
Monstern da hinten aufzunehmen die mich
dann abschießen die ja Armbrüste haben
also wie Skelette nur noch mit mehr
Leben und so das wird schon ihre jetzt
hat sich dann wieder geladen der Tank
aber gut meine Damen und Herren ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich würde an der Stelle
dann glaube ich auch die heutige Episode
Minecraft beenden es ist jetzt nicht äh
krank viel passiert in die Richtung
warte ich pack diese Blöcke immer glaube
ich doch lieber in diese Kiste hier und
hier vorne lasse ich komplett das alles
mit Steinen drin es ist jetzt nicht was
passiert in die Richtung von wegen ey
krass fail oder hey Luca das und das
gebaut oder das und das erreicht was wir
allerdings geschafft haben ist dass wir
allen Inseln ein Besuch abgestattet
haben außer der Insel wo wirklich die
Monster auf uns warten von daher wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne einen Daumen
hoch unter dem Video hier da abonniert
meinen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke
um weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen
meine Damen und Herren ich werde hier
vorne jetzt erstmal ein großes Feld noch
mal ganz kurz hin bauen denn die Zeit
haben wir auf jeden Fall noch mal eben
zack nehmen wir den Wasser einmal mit
kann ich auch mal eben kurz die Melone
abbauen und ich nehme mir auch noch mal
eben kurz Weizenkörner mit denn wir
benötigen auf jeden Fall ein etwas
größeres Feld noch mal für Weizen weil
[Musik]
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott bin ich blöd
ich bin so blöd ich dachte gerade ich
hätte irgendwie mein Wasser zerstört
ich weiß aber auch nicht wie man so blöd
sein kann weil ich jetzt auch einfach
von hier auch wieder naja ihr merkt ich
bin ein bisschen am Arsch ich nehme mal
eben kurz meine Hacke kann mich von hier
dran ja perfekt schau mal Zack und dann
können wir hier vorne beim Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam und Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam setz mal kurz die Weizenkörner hier
drauf ich weiß das Wasser tatsächlich
auch reichen würde wenn ich nur einen
Block hier hinsetzen würde ich finde es
aber so so ein bisschen schöner weil es
halt mehr wie so eine Farm aussieht und
ich werde tatsächlich auch jetzt glaube
ich mal eben nee wir lassen den See
erstmal
oder habt ihr eine bessere Idee was ich
mit dem See vielleicht machen kann
weil ich finde die nicht so schön
ich könnte ihn halt theoretisch hierhin
das Haus packen aber da will ich
eigentlich meinen Garten haben mit so
Bäumen und somit so verschieden deswegen
soll da noch eine Fichte wachsen
vielleicht noch eine schwarzeiche deine
Ecke ich weiß es nicht
und ich mache so einen Fluss von da
hinten rum einmal hier so ein Graben
weiß es nicht muss vielleicht noch ein
bisschen mehr in die Challenges denken
[Musik]
na ja Sonne geht unter auch wunderschön
ne
damit möchte ich die Folge beenden komm
wir gehen in der nächsten Folge startet
dann äh Sonnenaufgang dann gehe ich noch
mal kurz gleich pennen aber an der
Stelle ist ein schönes Ende macht's gut
wir sehen uns die Tage wieder beim neuen
neuen Part
ich schon wundervoll hier geworden alles
ne schon klasse